so basically these girls will go on live
and people will pay to send them emojis
and then they're reacting as if they are
an NPC like a non-playable character
they're just like we need sound for it
yeah
yes yes I've seen this girl so good yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes
ice cream's still good yes yes yes
ice cream's still good yes yes yes no no
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes oh thank you baby this is
so it's like
sort of uh like annexing like anime
culture acting as an NPC people giving
them stuff and then them reacting
depending on what the thing that's given
to them is yeah kids go outside right
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's [__] weird to get money shots to
the girls though because they don't get
naked they don't do anything like that's
really you can tell your kids this and
it's [__] weird but you could be like
I made this girl I looked it up she made
125 000. how sad would you be if your
mom had a video of that I thought about
this though
it's way worse or on events yeah but
like Mom really you was doing this I
thought about this do I I thought of
maybe it's just like an acting rule like
I went to a haunted house one time and I
remember thinking these guys are so into
playing these [__] zombies
because they want to act that badly and
they're getting paid like 12 an hour and
they like act like zombies I know but
why this is weirder but they're making
125 this girl's making 500 000
apparently and then a a kid in a [__]
haunted house in New York City is making
13 an hour to put on makeup
walk all slow sliding their [__] left
foot eight hours a day 13 an hour
500 000 a year yeah I guess you got a
point there's something like implicitly
sexual about this that is unsettling to
me that's that's my only weird
delineation for that [__] weird
there's something sexual about that it
just it it people see it as sexual this
is the way the way y'all look at feet is
the way I look at this for sure I don't
get it
no I think it's just the girl
sexual this was a guy doing this it
wouldn't be sexual yeah it's not weird
right I thought that that's weird yo
that's weirder than feet it's not even a
question if you're into that the girl
has no problem but donate money that's
weird as [__] yeah
but you know this weird no I I put it on
the scene you out of your mouth I'm
putting that on the same like your feet
and pain for that while these girls
pedicures and people don't like feet
yeah but you're not not paying one feet
is crazy
that's what I'm saying pay for fee and
paying for this the same [__] yeah yeah
it takes the thrill out of it like let
me go on Instagram and zoom in twice
I do do that bro there's a lot of girls
that they got they're all burkled up on
their feet they hide the dogs and it's
just like bruh
you're a western woman covering your
whole feet like that
oppressed exactly like how dare you like
let let a man
tell you to keep your [__] toes
covered why would you let a man oppress
you like that take it off be a liberated
woman it's July like get them [__]
toes out there Flex them up
real talk you got that dog in here yeah
you do and you need to let them out
[Laughter]
hot dog
hot dog no I've been paying yeah this is
ridiculous I was talking about this he's
like how different is this than like the
guy that would dress up all gold and
stand in like Times Square or whatever
oh what a great analogy like how
different like it requires like not
really any talent but we pay them for
being still yeah
he's only paying we don't care if
they're in gold
it grabs my attention long enough to
know you've been still
but I'm paying you for being still not
for being in Gold yeah yeah if you're
just a dude sitting there like this I
wouldn't even notice I walk by but if
you painted all gold you're like this is
my oh you still go
upstairs you ever seen one guy that's
still you give him money that you see
another guy's Stiller and you're like
[__] I should go get my money from the
other still guy give it to this guy
because he's way Stiller he never did
that Mark I never knew I've never done
that I did that before I did do it I saw
a guy still and I was like [__] this guy
is so much Stiller and the other still
guy because like they compete they beat
I've seen them you could pay both too
you could go
[Music]
[Laughter]
holy [__]